let's get right into this week's world
famous mailbag if you have a message for
me hopefully substantive hopefully
not containing slurs you can email info
davidpakman.com and many of you do
and we review a handful or so of a
couple handfuls i guess depends on the
size of your hand um a handful of those
emails every single week starting
sometimes with people who don't like me
dakota wrote in with the subject you're
a village idiot now
almost a requirement is that you use the
wrong form of your versus you are and
indeed that's what dakota does
you're a village idiot my
a village idiot okay you spit on all the
graves of all the fine people
who have fought for this country and die
for your lazy ass
anybody know what they're talking about
you piss on the graves of all the fine
people who have gave their lives for
you can say the s
and lies you spume
you s on the lives of the family members
who have given their sons and daughters
so you slime ball can lie like you do
you are garbage
and an effing waste of sperm
please go back to school and get an
education and maybe you can get a job
on cnn
you're
a loser that's y-o-u-r
i think this is sort of like a presented
without comment type of scenario
let's move on
this one almost
just as bad
jeremy wrote in
with the subject commie idiot
this email
you have to describe them if case people
are listening written in all capital
letters
jeremy writing
hey commie genius if there's global
warning
why is it so cold here in texas more
like global cooling
were sick of te
fake news media and you're dumb
the only medai we trust now is oan and
newsmax
i hope you freeze to death spelled like
the great drummer josh freese not freeze
i hope you freeze to death with your
global warming and covet hoax
p.s you're gay y-o-u-r you're gay
pps trump won by a landslide he's still
my president and yours takami just wait
till march 4 you and the other commies
will be arrested the military is taking
cone troll and trump is in charge
education
critical thinking
mental health treatment
media literacy
many deficits in this country
exposed
by the mailbag all right let's get into
more substance substantive stuff felix
wrote in
saying trump guilty of numerous felonies
why not prosecuted it's a fair question
dear david sir i genuinely don't
understand it trump seems to be guilty
of numerous felonies why isn't he
prosecuted why not convicted why is
there obviously no interest in doing so
are there serious consequences for the
person who would have the power to do it
this person could go down in the history
books
wouldn't it also be something the
democrats could use well in the election
campaign i genuinely don't get it
um yeah these are these are all fair
questions and what we learned last week
is that the prosecutors investigating
trump in manhattan believed he had
indeed committed multiple provable
felonies
and resigned so did mark pomerance the
prosecutor resigned because he
thought it clear that there was no
actual plan to prosecute trump he said
we've done the investigation
we have the evidence the evidence is
solid enough we could prove this stuff
in court but there's no interest in
prosecuting and as i've said before
there's big hesitation to be the first
to prosecute i believe if you saw one
prosecution of trump that you would see
many and what they're afraid of
i don't know at the end of the day
as many of you know we did start
publishing the david pakman show clips
to the right wing platform rumble
langdon wrote in about rumble and saying
it's not so much free speech hey david
when i saw you joined rumble i figured i
would join as well and test their claims
of being immune to cancer culture and
100 free speech as you probably know
videos and comments are rated by the
number of rumbles received you can rate
a video or comment with a positive or a
negative rumble so for example if a
comment gets four positives and six
negatives your net rumble is minus two
when you get into the negative
your comment is automatically hidden and
you are not allowed to reply to any
replies to your original comment this is
not a shock
this is not a shock and there is no i
mean listen we all know that that
we're a free if a platform markets
itself as being a free speech platform
it's already kind of weird you know when
i think of
platforms i think about their
functionality and utility youtube
the biggest video sharing site in the
world oh it's about sharing videos
that's what it's about
um uh tik tok it is a rapidly growing
vertical format short form video content
oh okay that's what it's about
when someone says this is a free speech
platform it's almost not even really a
meaningful mission or description and uh
you should anytime you hear that
you should at least be wondering what
the hell are they talking about
uh let's see mike wrote in
about my appearance on the right
right-wing michael knowles show saying
dear david pakman coming from a
conservative perspective i heard you on
the michael knowles show this morning
and wanted to thank you for coming
across the isle to have such a civil
conversation about such polarizing
issues
i was extremely impressed in the way you
engaged him i meandered over to your
site and again was quite impressed i'm
looking forward to exploring more of
your content i hope other daily wire
followers are as appreciative of your
willingness to debate these topics
something i find less and less of these
days best of luck yeah i actually did
get three
very nice emails from people who caught
my daily wire appearance here's another
one kyle hey really enjoyed your
perspective while you were on the
michael knowles show i don't agree with
everything he said i don't agree with
everything he says but finding different
opinions where crap is not shoved down
our neck
without a moment to hear a counter
opinion is not always easy to find i
appreciate you having a conversation
with them and keeping them honest i
appreciated your insistence be heard so
i could understand your perspective
better even if it challenged my own
views
this is this is great this is great to
see unfortunately the vast majority of
the messages i got were horribly
anti-semitic and just slurs and attacks
but
i did get three nice messages um
from that appearance
carrie wrote in
carrie says hey david love your show my
whole family watches together every
night miss you on weekends not sure if
you've covered this but it would be
interesting to delve into the psychology
behind why some people believe in
conspiracy theories there must be a
certain personality type that has the
tendency to be drawn into conspiracy
over truth and facts have a great day it
is an interesting topic we've studied it
extensively and i've done a number of
interviews and at the end of the day
one of the in talking with a person
you'll sometimes
learn that they don't like uncertainty
and not liking uncertainty often goes
hand in hand with being susceptible to
conspiratorial thinking
and the underlying kind of idea
is
when terrible things happen seemingly
that are random
that can be really tough for people
who want to believe everything is
certain everything is planned everything
is predictable and happens for a reason
and so it starts to become preferable to
them to believe instead of wow that was
a random bombing i could have been there
or my loved ones could have been anybody
could have been there that's crazy
completely unpredictable
instead it's more comforting in a way to
know
there's not random bad stuff that was a
planned event it was a false flag it was
whatever
that
idea or that feeling
is common to a lot of conspiratorial
thinking not all and there's much more
to it but that is something we've
explored and very much uh worthwhile
last one today is from judy i'm sorry
it's from joseph
and it's about the katanji brown jackson
hearings and it makes no sense the
subject line is
judy demeaning yourself
i don't know what that means anyway it
says david
when you just lie
and act like justice's barrett and
kavanaugh were not qualified for the
supreme court based on their resume
you just demean yourself
both were highly qualified just as
katanji brown jackson is when you feel
the need to lie
and ignore reality you undermine
everything you say
i never said
barrett and kavanaugh
were unqualified
what i said were two things and this is
where please react to the things i say
not the things you heard or want me to
have said
what i pointed out was if you look at
her experience across eight different
areas of
law and judging
judge jackson is more qualified
than all nine currently on the court
that's one thing i said and i believe
that that's true if you look at your
experience not only as a federal judge
but on a sentencing commission and you
look at all those things she has more
types of experience than any of the nine
currently on the court do
in addition i said
the idea
that kavanaugh and barrett could be
qualified and jackson isn't is laughable
so i never said kavanaugh wasn't
qualified
i never said barrett wasn't qualified
what i said is it's cartoony
to suggest
kavanaugh and barrett might be qualified
but jackson is not
that doesn't make any sense so joseph
critical listening
critical listening very very important
skill to learn some we used to call it
active listening in school
let's learn it we have a great bonus
show for you today sign up at
joinpacman.com
to get access
we will be
a little bit of a different schedule
going on next week but i will tell you
about it
soon but don't miss today's bonus show